[Music]
good afternoon my name is Paul gray and
it is my privilege to welcome all of you
here on this rainy afternoon to Kresge
Auditorium and also to welcome the MIT
folks at the Lincoln Laboratory in
Lexington who are watching live and
people perhaps all over the world who
are maybe watching live on the Internet
I would like to thank the Ford Motor
Company for its sponsorship of these
Nobel laureate lectures presentations
panels now in their fourth year this is
the sixth lecture in that series
the others are are listed in your
program book and with the addition today
of professors Friedman and sharp these
programs have brought ten Nobel
laureates to this stage not all to this
stage one over in them in building 26
seven of whom were are members of the
MIT faculty following the lecture in the
lobby here in Kresge there will be a
reception and we hope you will join us
for that the title this afternoon is
defining the boundaries Homeland
Security and its impact on scientific
research the panel and the question
period afterwards will be moderated by
president Charles vest 15 president of
MIT who has been deeply involved himself
in these issues through his service on
the President's Council of Advisors in
science and technology and other
Washington activities president vest
thank you Paul and good afternoon the
topic of the relationship of Homeland
Security to scientific research and
education in this country has been of
great interest to the educational and
research community during the last two
years fundamentally we have been
concerned about two sets of issues
restrictions on people visas for
international students and scholars the
SEVIS computer system for information
tracking and access of students to
so-called sensitive areas of study and
also restrictions on scientific and
research information and materials the
use of phrases like sensitive but not
but not classified and something called
select agents that you will be hearing
more about the point is that we need to
achieve both security and to adhere to
our basic American values of openness we
need to preserve the processes by which
the scientific community carries out its
work to generate new knowledge for
humankind during this period MIT has
sought to play a positive role in
furthering dialogue and sound
policymaking and that's precisely why
we're gathered here today now how did
all this come about
let me begin with a bit of chronology in
May of 2001 springtime May of 2001 the
bipartisan Heart Rudman Commission on
national security in the 21st century
prophetically warned attacks against
American citizens on American soil
possibly causing heavy casualties are
likely over the next quarter century
equally important this Commission stated
second only to a weapon of mass
destruction detonating in an American
city we can think of nothing more
dangerous
and a failure to manage properly science
technology and education for the common
good over the next quarter century prior
to 2001 the university research
community had faced a number of
complicated issues about export control
of scientific research that had limited
certain international engagement in
basic research involving the use of
satellites and high-performance
computing in August of 2001 MIT began to
form an ad-hoc faculty committee chaired
by professor sheila widnall to review mi
t--'s policies and principles regarding
openness of research and especially our
policy that no classified research can
be conducted on our campus then as we
all know on September 11th 2001 3,000
innocent people died in the murderous
attacks on the World Trade Center the
Pentagon and in the countryside of
Pennsylvania the federal government thus
had thrust upon it a daunting
responsibility to protect the lives of
people in the United States but to do so
within a new complicated environment far
different from that of the Cold War
years during which our national defense
had largely been shaped protecting us is
of course a fundamental responsibility
of our federal government and this new
world of homeland and international
security presented opportunities to the
research university community to serve
through security related research and
development activities MIT is engaged in
this kind of service in a variety of
ways but the academic community also
realized very quickly that reactions to
these all-too-real dangers would
inevitably pose conflicts with some of
our most deeply held values and indeed
with the fundamental methodology of
we anticipated that immigration policy
and access of international students and
scholars to our campuses and to our
scientific meetings would come into
question we anticipated restrictions on
publication and open scientific dialogue
about topics that can be thought of to
be of potential use by terrorists and we
worried that safeguards and restrictions
on the use of our in our laboratories of
potentially dangerous materials
especially biological agents would be
established in ways that might not be as
thoughtful as possible indeed each of
these concerns became real in the months
following 9/11 the passage of the
Patriot Act in late October 2001
affected both immigration policy and
raised the issue of limited access to
what were termed sensitive areas of
study in our universities international
students scholars and visitors to the
u.s. were subjected to new reviews
interviews delays and more frequent
denials of visas you'll define terms
like sensitive but unclassified more
frequently entered research policy and
research contracts the editors of a
large group of important journals and
life sciences established a
self-policing mechanism to restrict
publication of information that might be
key to the development of unusually
dangerous mechanisms of bioterrorism
protocols for researchers to control the
availability of an access to
particularly dangerous substances turns
terms select agents were put in place so
the issue became how can we be both
secure and open the goal became the
establishment of sound federal policy at
MIT we believe that openness of our
campus to students scholars and faculty
from all over the world
is one of our greatest straw
and indeed is at the heart of the
phenomenal success of the American
research university we also believe that
scientific progress depends on open
international dialog publication of data
repetition and verification of research
results we believe that we have a
responsibility to apply our talents and
our expertise to keep the nation and
world secure it is essential that we
balance these interests and I for one
believe that it is possible to do so but
only if we approach it with great care
mit often working together with other
universities has pursued a three part
agenda consists of speaking out
forcefully on threats to our openness
reaffirming articulating and living by
our basic principles and engaging in
productive dialogue with federal
policymakers to solve problems together
as we gather here today these issues are
still very much in play and we have the
privilege of hearing two of mi t--'s
most distinguished faculty members think
aloud about them Jerry Friedman 1990
Nobel laureate and physics former
director of our laboratory for nuclear
science former head of our Department of
Physics former president of the American
Physical Society and and very important
to today's discussion professor Friedman
was a member of mi t--'s ad-hoc faculty
Committee on access to and disclosure of
scientific information professor
Friedman will be our first speaker he
will be followed by Phil sharp professor
Phillip sharp was awarded the Nobel
Prize in Physiology or medicine in 1993
Phil is a former director of our Center
for cancer research the former head of
the MIT biology department
and he is the founding director of the
McGovern Institute for brain research
phil is a frequent high-level advisor on
science and medical care policy in
Washington and as I think you will learn
during the afternoon perhaps the most
complex set of issues that we have to
face as a scientific community are those
revolving around life sciences and
bioterrorism so with no further
introduction professors Friedman and
sharp will speak to us following that we
will open up for a dialogue with all of
you
[Applause]
Thank You Chuck for your instant
introduction it's a great pleasure to be
here today to speak on this important
topic the horrific events of September
11th changed the American landscape in
many ways these events have clearly
demonstrated that we face a continuing
threat of terrorism at home and abroad
just as efforts to defend against
terrorism have caused some erosion of
our civil liberties they have also put
pressures on the free flow of scientific
information in times of threat or war
our nation has always had to strike a
balance between the free exchange of
information and secrecy in order to
prevent sensitive information from being
exploited by our enemies regulating the
disclosure of certain types of
information is certainly necessary
however excessive regulation of the flow
of scientific and technological
information is detrimental to our
national interest it will damage
research efforts that could enhance our
national security as well as stifle work
that can improve our people's health
strengthen our economy and straighten
our economy how to establish the proper
balance is an issue of crucial
importance to the academic community
there's also the issue of how the
academic community can best contribute
to the war on terrorism and do this
without inviting an atmosphere of
secrecy on campus that could jeopardize
the openness and research and education
that has served us so well there's a
long history of universities providing
service to the nation times of need a
notable example of this was the
development of the first self-sustaining
chain reaction on the campus of the
University of Chicago during World World
War two
a development that was essential to the
completion of the Manhattan Project
during this period MIT also made crucial
contributions to the war effort
the most prominent of these was the
radiation laboratory which was set up on
the MIT campus with the objective of the
developing radar systems for aircraft
ships and anti-aircraft guns MIT had
been chosen as a site for this
laboratory because microwave research
was already underway on campus by the
end of the war the laboratory occupied
15 acres of office space had a staff of
nearly 4,000 an annual budget of 13
million dollars and had produced over
100 different radar systems and devices
after the war the radiation laboratory
was quickly dismantled and its basic
research component became mi t--'s
research laboratory for electronics the
University of Chicago project and a
radiation laboratory were were secure
facilities where all work was classified
as secret staff members were
investigated by the FBI before they were
granted security clearance and were then
required to science secrecy agreements
visitors to these facilities were
carefully monitored the events of
September 11th forcefully told us that
we are now engaged in a new type of war
and it is clear that the academic
community can again provide valuable
service to the nation new efforts in
science and technology are needed to
help defend our nation against terrorism
but how is it's best done well the modes
used for such participation during
during world war ii service well in the
future the MIT administration took the
lead in trying to develop answers for
MIT an ad hoc committee the Committee on
the access to and disclosure of
scientific information was formed and
was charged to determine if current
policies provide adequate guidance to
consider mi t--'s role and classify
research in the context of the 21st
century the committee was chaired by
professor sheila widnall the other
members were professors Vincent Chan
Steven graves
Harvey's Sapolsky and myself the report
of this committee titled in the public
interest was issued on May 15 2000
to some of its major conclusions are
given in the following quote MIT remains
committed to a strong role of public
service and as appropriate to expanding
the scope of that service such an
expansion can include facilitating
faculty members to serve the net than -
in the nation's and national security
needs within the framework laid out in
our report
however after examining the implications
from the conduct of classified research
on campus we conclude that retaining an
open research environment with free flow
of research results and information on
the MIT campus is the best way for MIT
to fulfill its public service
responsibilities therefore we recommend
that no classified research should be
carried out on campus that no student
graduate or undergraduate should be
required to have security clearance to
perform thesis research and that no
thesis research should be carried out in
areas requiring access to classified
materials unquote the reason for this
last recommendation is clear directing a
student to do classified work for a
thesis project would do the student a
great - service such a student would not
be able to share research results with a
general scientific community and thus
would be deprived of scientific feedback
and also the use of this research work
to obtain a job imagine a student
talking to a prospective employer and
saying I'm sorry but I can't tell you
what I did for my thesis that is not a
good recipe for career advancement
classified research is governed by laws
and regulations that would require that
a dual research and management system be
set up on campus if such research were
embedded in campus units this
partitioning of activities would
severely reduce the accessibility of
personnel engaged in classified research
from involvement with community at large
including peer interactions student
involvement departmental and
arbitrary views and promotion
considerations there also would be
security restrictions against foreign
visitors and all uncleared faculty
students and staff that would deny them
access to areas where classified
research is done this would inevitably
create two separate classes of
individuals on campus there are a number
of other undesirable ramifications of
classified research on campus that but
unfortunate I don't have time to discuss
them today as in the past our academic
community has a special responsibility
to serve the nation in time of threat
when classified work is involved in
these efforts it should be separated and
sequestered in facilities that are
removed from the main MIT campus and no
classified work should be extended to
campus the compute the committee
concluded that there are several
organizations that can provide access to
classified facilities to enable MIT to
carry out the classified portions of
their research the most prominent of
these is MIT Lincoln Laboratory but
several other organizations could also
provide such access the committee also
addressed the possibility of a national
emergency during which the nation
requires a rapid near-term access to
specialized on campus facilities and
expertise examples of this would be the
need for forensic analysis of biological
materials materials preparation and the
use of other facilities and expertise
for some significant national need other
than research even if this type of
assistance requires restricted asset
access and special procedures the
committee recommended that MIT should
make such expertise available for a
short time response with the requirement
of a time dependent sunset clause the
committee came to these conclusions in
the basis of two sets of principles
first
the values which we believe govern the
operation of MIT or any other Institute
of learning and research and second the
great importance of our education and
science enterprises to the future of our
nation the fundamental mission of MIT
rests upon four values unfettered
transmission of knowledge through
educational activities creation of new
knowledge through research and other
scholarly activities service to the
nation and service to humanity to
fulfill it to fulfill its mission
we believe that MIT must have an open
intellectual environment education and
scholarship are best served through the
unconstrained sharing of information and
by creating the opportunities for free
and open communication such an
environment enables students to be
exposed to the most current knowledge
and allows scholars to build upon each
other's work peer evaluation of research
methods and findings can only result
from open sharing and debate within the
scientific community these are crucial
mechanisms to ensure the continued
quality and progress of science the
essential point is that the well-being
of our nation
will often to be damaged if Education
Science and Technology suffer as a
result of any practice that
indiscriminately discourages or limits
the open exchange of ideas and
information a government report issued a
few years ago discussed by Professor
vest examine the emerging global global
security environment this report titled
new world cunning American security in
the 21st century issued in 1999 by the
heart Rudman Commission was prophetic
about American vulnerability to heart
through terrorist attacks in their
examination of current threats to
national security the heart grodman
Commission concluded and this is a
during quote from the ones that
Professor vest gave the inadequacies of
our systems quote the inadequacies of
our systems of research and education
posed a greater threat to US national
security than any potential conventional
war we might imagine openness enables
MIT to attract educate and benefit from
the best students faculty and staff from
around the world over the course of many
years immigrant scientists as well as
foreign visitors and students have
contributed enormously to the American
education and educational and scientific
enterprises they have enriched our
knowledge and culture promoted the
growth of our economy and improve the
quality of our lives
professor Alice gasps vice president for
research at MIT has assembled some
statistics that reflect the importance
of foreign-born individuals in our
education and research enterprises for
example 41% of engineering graduate
students and 39% of mathematics and
computer science graduate students in
the United States our international and
large fractions of international
scholars are also seen in the sciences
roughly half of these students remain in
the United States and contributes
significantly to our economy and
education and research efforts nearly
40% of u.s. engineering faculty and more
than one-third of you u.s. Nobel
laureates are foreign-born
additionally nearly half of the
scientific and medical professionals at
the National History Interest Institutes
of Health are foreign nationals in these
difficult times the Institute should not
be forced to make judgments about which
foreign nationals can have access to
which courses research and publications
once a visa is granted for nationals
should have free access to all
educational and research programs on
campus if as a result of the war on
terrorism the government enacts
burdensome regulations in BA
students and scholars from abroad it
will hinder our ability to recruit the
best and the brightest international
students and scholars this will severely
damage our productivity in leadership in
science and technology it is ironic that
such overzealous measures to protect the
nation will actually weaken our security
because of their adverse effects on
research and education there are now new
threats to openness on campus as a
result of recent Rajee legislation there
are new restrictions that are being
placed in our academic research that
fall outside of the category of
classification following the September
11th events Congress passed the USA
PATRIOT Act which among its many
directives prohibits restricted persons
from possessing receiving shipping or
transporting about 40 specified
biological agents designated as select
agents the Patriot Act defines
restricted individuals as certain
foreign nationals in addition to certain
categories of US citizens these
categories comprise citizens who have
been disarmed this honorably discharged
indicted or convicted of certain crimes
who are illegal drug users or who have
had mental illness as of now very few
laboratories at MIT utilize select
agents in research however the Secretary
of Health and Human Services has the
statutory power to expand that list of
select agents and this is likely to
happen the expanded list could have a
much greater impact on MIT particularly
on areas that do biological research
additional training security and
physical restrictions on access to the
facilities will be required to comply
with the Act and because of such
restrictions research involving select
agents may have to be moved off campus
the position that biologic biologists
find themselves in today is quite
different from that of physicists during
it's the second world war in the
development of nuclear weapons a clear
separation could be made between
research that was and was not related to
national security the investigation of
fissionable nuclei was deemed critical
to national security and classified but
research in other areas of nuclear
physics was not in the years prior to
Manhattan Project a lie physicist
engaged in self-censorship by not
publishing research on uranium although
they discussed the results privately in
contrast such a clear separation is
difficult to make in biomedical research
research results from almost any basic
area of molecular biology has the
potential of being used for bioterrorism
this has led to calls for biologists to
self-censor
the publication of the work it has also
led the decision of the editors of more
than 20 leading scientific journals to
use as one of the criteria for accepting
or rejecting an article the question of
whether its publication poses a threat
to national security
these are important issues that I am
sure professor sharp will address
clearly it is not an easy matter to
establish the proper boundaries between
scientific openness and the restrictions
needed to enhance security this critical
issue calls her renewed dialogue between
the science and technology communities
and policymakers only through such
collaboration consents about policies be
developed I would like to conclude with
remark by John Hamre a former Deputy
Secretary of Defense he said quote if
the scientific community doesn't take
the lead in dealing with the reality of
the bioterrorist threat the security
community will take over and do the job
in ways that are likely to be wrong
unquote this is the very important
challenge that the scientific community
faces thank you
[Applause]
it's a fee
old friends and people who have spoken
very wisely today from the podium about
the issue of national security I want to
discuss these issues and related topics
from the perspective of biological
science and as a member of the MIT
community in addition we as scientists
and engineers who collectively do novel
science through the discovery of new
relationships and the solving of
problems by the application of new and
developing new engineering principles
have a special responsibility to enter
into the discussion of how these
advances are to be used by society even
how society can protect itself from
these new advances and that the latter
issue is more relevant for the topic
today I want to begin by outlining the
three points I hope to comment on and
justify one biological scientists do not
know how to make novel bio weapons to
infection by natural pathogens is a much
bigger threat than bioterrorism and
three in developing national security we
should be sensitive not the damage
public health systems which protect us
from both natural infections and
potential attacks by bioterrorism first
speaking about bio weapons we do not
have to fear a lot in my opinion of a
terrorist using the principles of modern
biology to make a significant better
pathogen than already exists in nature
there may be a few possible simple
exceptions to this statement perhaps
introducing drug resistance into a
bacteria or fungi to make it resistance
to treatment by a known antibiotic
however even this would change the
treatment part of containing an attack
but it would not basically change the
nature of the and
process and therefore probably the
impact of the process Nature has created
betch better infectious diseases than
current science can design in it it is
these natural agents that we should be
concerned about as potential terrorist
agents let me illustrate how difficult
it might be to develop a bioterrorist
weapon for terrorists to try to create a
new weapon they would immediately
encounter two major problems first is
our ignorance of the necessary
properties to engineer into an agent to
make it a bioweapon
we simply do not understand the
infectious process well enough nor how
the immune system responds to infections
nor how the characteristics of
transmission from one person to another
is necessary to make a contagious
infection to design from first
principles in a new bio weapon in
addition to this lack of knowledge there
is a major experimental challenge how
can one test a new engineered agent to
be a bioweapon the only way that you
could do this is to do a field test the
equivalent of a clinical trial for a
drug it's release the agent
unappropriate conditions and see what
the effect would be this would seem to
be impossible to do without being
detected thus we have to worry about the
potential use of known pathogens as
terrorist agents these could be agents
as smallpox or anthrax or Ebola or
perhaps even poliovirus
if perchance we stop vaccinating against
this virus in the general public the
second point I'd like to make is that
public health risks from current
infectious agents are significantly
greater than any potential risk from Ana
terrorist attack with a biological agent
let me illustrate this it's difficult to
comprehend that over the past twenty
years and it was only 20 years ago when
HIV was identified as an infectious
agent that appeared in certain
population centers it's only 20 years
ago that age
appeared 20 million people have died
from HIV infection 40 million people are
infected by HIV today
thus a death toll from this type of
natural infection far exceeds what we're
going to see in my opinion from any new
bioweapon you can have a similar
question
imagine what death toll might be like if
the SARS virus which appeared last year
in the winter had spread worldwide the
death rate in certain regions of the
world from the individuals who are
infected by this virus within a period
of four to five weeks or so or a couple
of months was approximately 10% of all
infected people spread of SARS
to population centers in this country
would have been both a health and an
economic disaster we could continue on
this record of natural infections that
cause widespread mortality one of the
major concerns for the biological
community and the infectious disease
community is the possible re-emergence
of a pandemic flu such as that appeared
in 1919 across the world this would
cause literally millions of deaths in
this country in a period of year I have
not mentioned other known pathogens such
as malaria's affection disease that take
a constant death toll but these natural
infections are much greater risk in my
opinion than any risk we face from a bio
weapon in comparison to this disease
toll caused by natural pathogens what's
the record of terrorist attack by
biological agents and I use the word
terrorist here either as a deranged
individual or a group of people or a
nation that's involved in attack in
recent times I can think of the
following five people died from the
anthrax being mailed sent to the public
mail in fact most of my biological
friends we were amazed that only five
people died from anthrax being sent to
the mail we had the impression that it
was a much greater in
agent than that several years ago
anthrax was decades ago anthrax was
released from weapons factories in the
Soviet Union and tins and more people
died from that release the most damaging
example of biological warfare if you
want to call it that or it should be
called of which I'm aware is a transfer
of infectious diseases such as measles
and smallpox from European settlers to
indigenous populations across North
America and in other parts of the world
the lesson from this latter example
which we need to take seriously is the
deliberate spreading of natural
pathogens which can cause widespread
death and chaos is a much bigger concern
than any newly created by a weapon that
I can contemplate assuming that the
first two points are true then we should
use special precautions in making
policies relative to homeland security
and biological agents so as not to
impair the strong public health
community which protects us against
natural infections this public health
community includes educated physicians
infectious disease clinicians officials
responsible for clean air water and food
it also includes the Center for Disease
Control CDC NIH National Institute of
Health and the agencies of the state
governments similarly any new homeland
security policy should be particularly
careful not to impede research and
education concerning how infectious
disease spreads infection age affections
age and spreads and calls disease the
same research community and strong
health public health community effects
that protects us from ongoing infections
is the first that would detect a
terrorist attack and be responsible as
well for treating people who were
infected by that attack so how could
policy by Homeland Security and the
administration decrease our public
health capabilities and impede research
first would be if resources were
withdraw withdrawn from training and
facilities important for control and
treatment of diseases in the general
public the case for expanding resources
for control of infectious disease has
recently been made by report from the
Institute of Medicine among the editors
of this report is Josh letterman Josh
Lederberg president previous president
of the Rockefeller University and a
Nobel laureate in medicine Josh has been
concerned about these issues from some
time and the report makes a particularly
strong recommendation that the US needs
to work with other countries including
those with developing economies to gain
better control of global threats of
infectious disease with the rapid and
relatively inexpensive travel which is
available today any new infectious agent
which appears in anywhere in the world
can be an infectious agent in this
country in periods of an hour another
possible negative impact of homeland
security on our capability to deal with
infectious agents would be to implement
policies which inhibit research and
education in this area here there are
some dangers and Jerry Friedman has
commented on those from actions that are
being discussed the vitality of research
depends critically critically upon open
discussions and publications a potential
criticism of this necessary openness is
a concern that new research might inform
terrorists how to modify or use
biological agents in a terrorist attack
there are two examples of such research
which I would like to illustrate for you
it was discovered a few years ago in the
course of a research program that
insertion of an immune gene the
interleukin 4 gene a human gene into the
genome of a mouse Puck's bars this is a
bars of the same family of smallpox but
for a mouse resulted in of ours which
suppress
suppress the host animals immune system
making the virus highly lethal so the
bars killed the animal much more rapidly
if this was generally true for all
poxviruses and/or for all viruses it
could be a method of creating a more
lethal pathogen for man however it is
not clear that a lethal bars would be a
good bio weapon lethal viruses are
generally not good infectious viruses
good infectious diseases because they
kill the host and therefore do not
transmit from in in organism to organism
but this is somewhat beside the point
the question is should the paper be
published as a results that could
potentially indicate how to make a more
lethal bio weapon I would argue that the
risk of this publication leading to more
biological weapons are more effective as
I've Illustrated before is very small
alternatively these results could help
form the basis of a more complete
understanding of the process of the
human immune response to viruses and
that could lead to very much more
effective vaccines and treatments now
the resolution of this was that this
paper was published there has been some
discussion that one should publish such
papers without including the
experimental details of how to do the
manipulations they give rise to the
results and this type of discussion has
been basically rejected by the
scientific community because if you do
not include the details of how to
duplicate an experiment in a publication
you cannot proceed in scientific
progression another example is a paper
published last year in science
describing how to synthesize the genome
of poliovirus to make an infectious
agent the possibility that a terrorist
might learn how from this paper to
construct the genome of an infectious
virus led a congressman to call for an
investigation and censor and call for
censoring of the publication this uproar
was a little surprising to many members
of the scientific community because Dave
baldemar here at MIT had reported the
same experiment 20 years before when he
first cloned the genome of poliovirus
in the center for cancer research and
determined that you could add a DNA to a
cell and make an RNA virus replicate
thus not publishing this paper would
have been of little consequence in my
opinion but the broader question is
relevant should we restrict research on
the analysis of viral genome sequence
and structure because it might enable a
terrorist to make a farce the answer is
a responding no in my opinion because
this is the heart of modern biological
research without the analysis of viral
genomes we would seriously compromise
very seriously compromise the
possibility of developing vaccines and
diagnostic treatment the scientific
community is currently debating whether
there should be restrictions imposed by
the community itself on results relevant
to bioterrorism as Juri mentioned there
was a meeting at the National Academy of
Science in which editors of the germ
oast of the major journals agreed that
there would be an overview of
manuscripts real relevant to
bioterrorism and censorship of those
manuscripts which was considered
potentially enabling bioterrorism as far
as I'm aware this is the second example
of self-censorship by the biological
community the first was a moratorium in
the 70s on doing and describing or doing
specifically genetic engineering
experiments until we understood how to
handle the recombinant DNA revolution
that was ongoing
an indication of the scale of this
review in publication comes from results
that have been published from the
American Society of microbiology a
society that publishes most of the
journals in
disease they've examined 14,000 papers
published in 201 and 202 224 were tagged
as potentially sensitive and two papers
were withdrawn from publication in one
case the author's withdrew the
publication in the other case the paper
was modified to delete the offending
material there is soon to be released
from the National Academy a report on
the question of how to assure that
research will not be published which
will aid terrorism the recommendation in
this report have not been released
but scientists at MIT or reassured by
the fact that Gerry Fink the previous
director of the Whitehead Institute and
professor at MIT is sharing chairing the
committee and is preparing with his
colleagues the report now I believe that
some form of self-censorship as
unpleasant as it might be to in install
would be preferable by far from
censorship demanded by federal law the
latter would become highly political and
difficult to change as knowledge
advances an agreement among scientists
to be aware of the problems of
bioterrorism and its potential and to
not unwittingly eight it would seem
appropriate and reassuring to the public
which supports our research I suspect
that this will be a policy that will
evolve however we will have to wait as
the events unfold as I mentioned earlier
the major concern in developing rules to
reduce the risk of bioterrorism is not
to damage research which will protect
the public from future infections
natural infections now one way to
inflict such damage to such research is
to make the area of research of studies
so complicated and unappealing that
scientists will choose to work on other
areas declaring research on certain
agents select agents as sensitive or
are restricted yes professor Freeman
mentioned would make such research
unattractive there is a list of about 20
agents that have been identified in this
class
none of those agents isiah far as I'm
aware are under investigation here at
MIT however if this list were expanded
he could encompass many experimental
agents such as polio which we have used
many times in the lab and many other
viruses that we'll use in contemporary
research in very important ways and
impact on ongoing and important research
both here and around the world
finally the gesture by comments relative
to homeland security efforts to reduce
the risk of biological terrorism is for
the agency to work with the community to
create procedures and policies that are
potentially effective and do not reduce
our capabilities in public health and
research a simple way of stating this is
to put in place policies that can be
effective but do no harm to ongoing
activities in these areas the second
general conclusion is that any future
biological tech will probably involve
the distribution of a known pathogen
controlling access to these agents and
the technologies necessary to convert
them into weapons is very reasonable the
key here is to control activities with
the intent to create bio weapons and/or
attack using an infectious agent
implementing policies and procedures
which accomplish this will be difficult
but both the scientific community and
others and we cannot be assured of
complete protection there is no such
thing as complete protection in this
world the best defense will probably
come from a global effort to one detect
and control new emerging infections to
gain in from intelligence about the
activities concerning potential bio
weapons in other parts of the
and three to ensure the open
dissemination of knowledge about
biological science this country should
expand the resources it commits to
global health and international research
and I think this would make us all more
safe than we are today
thank you
I want to thank professors Friedman and
sharp very much for these deeply
thoughtful as well as provocative
presentations we are now going to take
questions from the audience for the next
30 or 40 minutes there are microphones
on stands in each of the two Center
aisles and I would ask that you step up
to those microphones and those of you
who have questions to ask begin to form
a line behind them I also would like to
ask that as we get into this you
restrict the length of your questions to
about a minute so that they can be well
focused and give our two colleagues an
opportunity to answer them we have the
first question over here please
we can't hear you hello
my place on top Friedman who I enjoy
your intellectual scholarship is this
considering that there is a lot of
secrecy in the industry to protect IPs
and this is for corporate games why
should it government engage in secrecy
not to protect citizens in as much as I
don't agree with this what it what do
you say that we disagree with industry
in this and coppy not be enough thank
you let me try to paraphrase question I
believe the question is that you have
spoken eloquently about the need for
openness when the issue is with the
government but there are analogous
issues with industry where there are
attempts to constrain the flow of
information in order to protect
intellectual properties that enough and
how do you view these two things it's a
very thank you for the question I'm
sorry I didn't quite hear it the first
time that's a very good question
mit has a policy that all research work
done a campus must be published
it cannot be withheld and any any
agreement with an industrial corporation
for sponsored research has in it that
such work cannot be impeded from
publication now there's one proviso
namely there can be a 30 to 60 day delay
while the company decides whether it
wants to apply for a patent but after
that period is over that work is
published and it can be disposed in all
its aspect and no proprietary
information can be taken out of it yes
ma'am the current administration doesn't
have a very good record in listening to
scientists an example being global
warming stem cell research oftentimes
the majority opinion of the scientific
community is not being
- what assurances can we have that the
administration or Washington will be
listening to the scientists in regard to
these issues of homeland security and
the best approaches well you know there
can be no assurances I think all the
scientific community can do is try to
organize as much as it can get a unified
point of view and speak with unified
voice and try to get as much pressure on
the government to adopt sensible
policies as possible I think there is
not much more than one can do but I
think the attitude that they may not
listen is not sufficient to stop us from
trying because otherwise one doesn't
accomplish anything so I think one has
to work harder hi I'm with the lab for
computer science here at MIT in my field
this came up about ten years ago when
the government was trying to regulate
the field of cryptography and the sale
of encryption programs and one of the
issues that came up then is we said if
we stop doing this as an industry the
rest of the world will catch up will
surpass the US and then we'll be faced
with a problem where we actually have
technology that's not as good as the
rest of the world and the response from
the government at the time was what we
need is some kind of delay we just need
to sort of stay ahead of the public
knowledge that's out there do you think
there's some similarity here and if so
what would be your response to that the
idea of delaying research before it
reaches the public I think there's maybe
a different but I doubt it
response from Computer Sciences there is
from biological science one never knows
when one's engaged in research where the
important insights are going to come
from and how they are stimulated and of
individuals head and therefore when you
start talking about significant delays
or restricting information
you are by that very act putting
yourself at a disadvantage either as a
country or an individual in staying
abreast of the absolute forefront of the
field in addition you certainly do send
away every one of the brightest stars
who could come into the field and change
the field so I think this is a policy
that doesn't work it only puts you at a
great disadvantage and slight delays are
still delays and important delays the
other thing I would say about biological
science though I believe in some areas
of biological science we in this
community in this country or breast of
the very forefront of that area in
infectious diseases we are probably just
about comparable to many other European
in particular communities in terms of
science so I think we need as I
commented to engage in a global activity
in this eye I can't see delaying as
being effective in doing anything sure
well I think the issue here is that
unless you have an international
approach to it all these things very
often are developed simultaneously in
different places and so in a certain
sense it is very hard to have it too
late very effective unless there is an
international consensus about how to how
to sort of secure this information there
have there there have been arguments
made and it may be these arguments made
different in different fields namely
that if there is a slight delay of some
sort it allows the the groups that are
have developed this ways of trying to
counter measures that could arise from
the release of this information now that
is also an argument and I think it
probably depends very much on the
circumstances I think if a policy which
is uniform for everything probably is
not is not a good policy if I might I'd
like to make a brief comment that ties
an aspect of these two last two
questions to
gather the major policy outcome of that
period when the questions about
cryptography were raised was national
security decision directive 189 SDNS DD
189 that was promulgated by then
President Reagan that drew a bright line
and it said that fundamental research in
the university was basically exempt from
restrictions and that the only mechanism
eken ISM for restricting it was
classification to go all the way to the
system that Professor Friedman mentioned
one of the things the scientific
community has worked very hard on in
these last two years is to remind the
administration that that remains the law
of the land
and indeed NS D D 189 has been restated
by Condoleezza Rice and also by by Jack
Marburger the director of Science and
Technology Policy and one of the things
we as a community have been working very
hard on is to be sure that it is really
implemented and if we do that we get
away from a lot of the fuzziness that
enables the bureaucracy to kind of get
in and and put restrictions where it
really should not be make another
comment about this the the example that
I mentioned about the uranium research
during the early days at world war ii
where there was a self embargo
publication is an example where one
wanted to try to and of course this kind
of research was going on all over the
world
and i guess there was a perception that
if something was new was discovered they
wanted to essentially not get it out as
quickly as as publication would permit
but I think the but there is an issue
here in general I mean those were on
their very special circumstances if you
start letting delays come in it's a very
slippery slope and one has to be very
careful that if that becomes a a kind of
methodology for a developing security
that they can get longer or longer or
longer and then also end up
being an infinite and so I think one
must be extremely careful that it has to
be maybe under certain extraordinary
circumstances and there are always
exceptions for extraordinary
circumstances one might contemplate such
a thing but in general one would not
want to have such a policy a lot of
people feel that the government's
regulations and select agents are unduly
restrictive and prohibit research and as
a result I guess over the last few
months especially we've seen a lot of
infectious disease specialists step out
of their fields and stop their research
on particular select agents and new
people coming into the field have been
discouraged from working on these agents
do you think or how do you feel that
this balances out with the security of
the nation and do you feel that the
Select agent policy pursued by the
government should be in place as it is
right now as I come in it I believe the
policy it's in place now will somewhat
discourage research in the area with
these select agents most of those select
agents include you know organisms such
as anthrax Ebola virus several other
highly infectious Marburg virus highly
infectious agents you would not want to
engage in research in with those agents
unless you were equipped with a very
high containment type facility which
would protect the investigators from
those agents but in as I mentioned we
don't have those agents here at MIT in
terms of current research but putting
restrictions in will discourage the
research and in time that could make you
more at risk for not being able to
control and identify those agents it's
only been a short period of time now
what the consequences will be in a
couple of years will become even more
clear
as question for dr. sharp I respect
Murphy's Law what could go around would
go round indeed I believe a major lesson
from the 11th of September isn't at the
United States entries theorem life as we
know it has all the time since the time
of its inception when the target of an
injurious and hostile environment as we
look at it we as a sophisticated society
have also become the target of hostility
to sit back today and close the doors as
you rightfully said which is very wrong
would just be a creating walls in front
of our basically high speeding in the
pathway of evolution I think we should
and I would like to seek your opinion
look at this hostility and noxious
action from some elements take advantage
of what they have done and evolved into
a higher stage I have been closing our
doors sitting back and letting them
damages even more by as was said
restricting our scientific research what
is your idea about going ahead instead
of waiting to get hit for the second
time which probably is a matter of when
not if to go ahead and start mass
vaccination against the major agents
like anthrax smallpox other agents I
understand some difficulty like Ebola
and other that they might be thinking or
considering to use against all of us
here so what is the administration's
policy today for all of us as a nation
regarding vaccinations
I'm personally feel it would be prudent
to go ahead and consistently consider a
mass vaccination against all these you
know dangerous and deadly agents rather
than ready to get hit for a second time
and maybe on a much broader basis thank
you I would say the following and I'll
answer your question that vaccination is
by far the most effective means of
protecting ourselves against most Varro
learn are bacterial or other agents and
that we should and as far as I'm aware
commit ourselves to pairing all the
vaccines we need to vaccinate the
population in a case of an attack but
let's take the example of smallpox the
vaccine now being used are available for
smallpox as a vaccine that's well over
50 or 70 years old
it has complications in terms of
infecting a small fraction of the people
who take the vaccine or give them I've
been given the vaccine that's
significant medical complications with
modern biological methodologies we
should be able to make a safer vaccine
and have that available upon demand for
treatment in terms of an infection the
same should be true of anthrax and a
number of other agents whether you need
to vaccinate the population now or wait
until you see a challenge and then
vaccinate the population I think is a
issue of what's at risk
how can you contain it who are put at
risk at what time either by vaccinating
or by waiting and seeing if the vaccine
if the infection appears I totally agree
with you in terms of working forward in
making new vaccines against most of
these agents would be the most
satisfactory way of potentially
protecting ourselves but for some of
these agents we don't have as far as I'm
aware you know model systems that we can
use to
develop and treat vaccines we need the
science to do that more questions yes
post doc did your Institute I'm a
historian of science I'm more general
question about where scientists think
they are today some of the case studies
he cited today we're from World War two
and from the Cold War MIT especially
profited greatly during the Cold War
basically funding was that made into a
great institution I'm sort of wondering
when you think about the war on
terrorism how do you really construct
the threat to science today and a real
threat to national security and what do
you see as necessary changes for science
practice in the next five to ten years
aside from some of the acts we've talked
about coming from Washington I mean do
you see the need for a possible return
to restricted dissertations and
basically black box dissertations in the
near future I mean do you see any
anything coming along the line for that
why or why not actually well I think
there's actually no need for restricted
or classified dissertations because the
truth of the matter is we have
facilities in which class of our
research can be carried out and as I
spoke as I mentioned them I talked it is
it is not a very good educational
experience for students to get involved
in classified research for thesis so I
think that that aspect has not changed
what may change is you when they have a
larger percentage of faculty members who
go to classified facilities to work
universities may give more leaves of
absence for this and if there are
periods of greater need so that there
can be that kind of mobilization but I
think that's what's going to happen as
long as we can keep the scientific
enterprise going as it is we will
maintain our strength if we let it get
involved in classification
classification sites at the University
it's it's it's and of course it's going
to be very detrimental to our scientific
enterprise and education so I don't see
much change from that point of view
perhaps a greater greater
participation as I said at certain
facilities hello professor sharp studied
the example of a global SARS epidemic as
a potential natural threat the fight
against SARS was special in the enormous
collaboration among researchers
worldwide
more typically researchers have tended
to somewhat selfishly hoard their
primary data in order to be the first to
publish it this can lead to delays in
disclosing primary data that would be
helpful in fighting an emerging epidemic
how do we help researchers overcome this
tendency to this desire to want to be
first to publish Natick academic paper
at the expense of fighting a global
threat such as an emerging epidemic and
what is the effect of security measures
on non-traditional means of disclosing
data such as over the Internet well
there is no question that the academic
community tends to want to be the first
to describe a describe a new phenomena
or identify a new agent but in many
cases that you know perceived me works
in conjunction with the first to
disclose and the first to discuss about
it in infectious diseases as you come in
at it now what as we have now a very
effective worldwide interplay between
World Health Organization's CDC and and
other national organizations in trying
to identify and combat global diseases I
doubt seriously I'm not an expert in
this area but I doubt seriously if
delays in terms of disclosure or
publication is significant in that area
I mean these people is by perception are
very committed to trying to control
infectious diseases in many cases we'll
put that aside in most cases to try to
be as effective as I can
a few days ago I heard on the radio an
ex colleague of yours Paul Krugman who
maintained that the ballooning tax that
the ballooning deficit that the
government creates may eventually be
used to to cut off popular programs
because the government will present the
people with the choice of either we
increase taxes to start paying for the
deficit or we kal popular programs so my
question is do you think that the same
argument eventually may apply to your
funding for research of this sort so are
we could we ever get into a situation
what the government would say will
present the people the option of either
we increase your taxes or we keep on
paying off for esa's programs that may
be potentially to be used by terrorists
do you see any indication of that and if
that happens how are you going to react
to this well as the deficit gets larger
which is getting quite large now
discretionary spending gets very small
and of course basic research comes out
of discretionary spending and it is
under threat especially when one does
not make the connection between the
importance of basic research and the
security to the country and so I think
it's very important again for the
scientific community to speak to the
government as forcefully as it can in a
unified voice and this has been
happening in many and many of these
societies across the country and in fact
there's been an approach to have all
societies get together and not plead for
their own particular discipline but to
plead for better funding in science
across the entire scientific spectrum
and that includes of course engineering
and so the idea is to have a balanced
portfolio in size and there is an effort
going on it's a very intense effort and
it's very it's a these are very
difficult times and as we said before
all we can do is work as hard as we can
to try to make sure that we don't fall
too far behind because if we if this
kind of funding does fall too far behind
it puts the country in great jeopardy as
per as
president vest played out in terms of
the heart Rodman report I also pointed
out our national security and next 25
years depends more on the health of our
science and education enterprises than
almost anything else and we underfund
them at great jeopardy to the country I
want to add one comment here we in the
biological community particularly those
people who are supported by the National
Institute of Health have had the great
fortune over the last five years to have
total support of biological science
doubled in terms of the NIH budget or
it's near doubled it's it's approaching
that my particular concern and I'm sure
my colleague jury and Chuck desks would
agree is that in the physical sciences
we've not seen anything like the
increase in support for research that we
have in biological sciences and as
biological science has become more
integrated into public health in and
systems and more complex ways of looking
at their interaction with the
environment and internally the input
from physics and engineering becomes
more and more critical
so I plead for particularly greater
support in the physical sciences now to
enrich this community in in great
universities like MIT I thank you that
very much appreciate the remark made by
Prosser sharp that we can't eliminate
the possibility hundred percent of any
biological agent being used as an
epidemic I'd like to draw a parallel to
how much of money should be spent and
homeland security I think the comments
were have more towards the impact of
homeland security on research but would
you like to also touch on welfare
spending as well as homeland security
spending for example the transportation
at
illustration would like to spend as much
money to eliminate any and all possible
occurrences of a security lapse but any
system with software as well as human
intervention is liable for such flaws so
where you see the limit on funding all
these things getting drawn
I can't address the specific limit or
what is reasonable for funding I would
have to say that we as a society are
very poor at making relative risk
judgments so if you have a particular
attack and it was a disaster attack in
911 or various other things it's hard
for us as a community to put relative
risk in perspective and then make
investments that would have the
appropriate benefits given the relative
risk and I think if I were you know
arguing about how much resources you
ship at the Homeland Security versus
other things I think you have to in you
know include in that conversation
what relative risk and relative benefit
will come from investment of a given
amount of dollars in this area versus
that area and that's a dialogue I would
like to to see elevated because I think
we're investing some very foolish money
I think you shared very well what how
MIT is responding to these risks and I
was just wondering if other universities
around the nation are responding in the
same way or if they're allowing more
students to work on confidential work
how the other universities are handling
let me comment a little on that we felt
it was really important because of a
mighty stature broadly in the scientific
and technological higher education
community to get out front of this issue
a little bit and speak quite clearly
early on in the hopes that we would
gather a lot of colleagues with us
a lot of the work that has been done on
policy of openness interaction
with the government from student visas
through the research questions here has
been done collectively by the
Association of American Universities
which about the top 60 public and
private research institutions but I have
to tell you that going forward one of my
real fears and I don't have a lot of
data to place on the table yet but one
of my real fears is that the combination
of budgetary pressures due to a weak
economy and lowered state tax bases and
so forth and the possible availability
of a lot of research that comes with
some significant restrictions that that
temptation is going to be very great for
a number of institutions so all we can
do is jawbone and work together and as I
said in my introduction try to clearly
articulate and then live by our
principles I consider it a danger and
it's a danger that I think every campus
should address overtly and not that many
are so I guess my question is that I
come I came from working and about at
Genentech many amass Churchill know so
always try to make into a discovery
versus drug who do you think so when the
company producing a drug they are
financially independent they don't need
anything else so you don't need the
government only anything because you
produce in something just like you grow
your vegetable you are you know whatever
now the question I want to ask is that
MIT is very famous on technology will
you ever think that MIT making their own
drugs you know you sell the drug and you
get a lot of money and the reason for
that is that MIT as a or at least I'll
speak from the biological research
community is a community that's most
effective in making new discoveries
relative to biological systems and we
had the great fortune
occurrence several decades ago as you're
aware of to have participated in the
discovery of recombinant DNA and from
that came the biotech community which
translated out into society and is now
taking that technology and making
practical drugs but to actually develop
a drug as you know from Genentech
requires large teams of people focused
on a specific objective over periods of
time and the motivation here has to be
focused on having an effective cost
effective highly therapeutic drug and
motivations of Education and motivations
of training and publication and free
disclosure and everybody being
individually creating so they can
develop their self talent is really
inconsistent with that type of activity
plus the fact that you have to invest
two to three hundred million dollars so
I think that business is the business of
the private sector it's best done there
and regulated there and that we play the
role of being the educator research
community that keeps trying to produce
the future which will allow you know
future developments of private sector
activities like that you can send all
the student to all these biotech company
that's fine that works well my gosh and
that leads me to think of a broader
question what could the value be of
directing funding from Homeland Security
to the more fundamental problem that of
debtors of dealing with the the cause of
the hatred and stealing with trying to
consider trying to prevent hatred from
affecting other people so is there a
value to funding development education
in communities that that would benefit
from from that and in hits encourage
ashamed a change in political mind shift
granted there will always be phonetics
pairs that
wants to cause harm but could this
potentially percent percentage be
diminished by a shift in funding
research well it seems to me there's
always use in funding the social and
political sciences to get a better
understanding of why there are
terrorists in the world and what are the
issues and trying to understand what the
what the strategies are what the motives
are because I think you know in a
certain sense those things have to be
understood too as well as getting
defenses against terrorism because in
the long run what you really want to do
is eradicate the sources of terrorism
not just defend yourself with a big wall
so I think in the in the grand scheme of
things clearly security is also best
gotten by increasing our understanding
in other areas in addition to Science
and Technology before that it's
important for the scientific community
to speak with one voice to unite I'm
wondering how me as an undergraduate and
anybody else in this room who would like
to could add our voice to the rest of
the scientific community I haven't had
much experience here at MIT this is my
first year but I'd like to know how I
could contribute there's one method one
can use most professional societies for
the sciences have days in which they go
and visit Washington talk to congressmen
and staffers and they find it very
effective to have graduate students come
along and talk about what they are
involved in and you know what what their
what their career development has been
and they make very very impressive
spokesmen and spokespeople I should say
for for for the sciences so I don't know
what field you're in but whatever field
you're in there is probably a
professional Society associated with it
you might find out when they have
visiting days most of them do and see if
you can go and participate one of the
things that I think is very important
for this
involves young people like you is that
we have contemporary cutting-edge
research going on in in universities
that are involved in education both at
an undergraduate and graduate level and
it has amazed me how fast fundamental
advances in science can percolate
through the community when students said
in a classroom can hear such discussions
move home and talk to their friends and
though they talk to their friends it's
an amazing system of educating a
democracy that's very valuable and I
hope this country never goes to the
research model in which research has
done in institutions and education is
done over there because I think it it
does delay in a significant way
how a society can judge technology
understand it and use it more
effectively so I mean you you
participate in multiple ways you don't
know about but just being you a very
practical points to this in addition to
the professional societies that
Professor Friedman mentioned we are very
active at MIT and an organization we
helped found called the science
coalition there's another group called
research America that has in the past
emphasized the life sciences there is a
coalition on behalf the National Science
Foundation and every year there are two
or three days that we help organize to
get students to Washington to tell their
personal stories I absolutely agree with
Jerry the only the only group that's
more effective in graduate students or
undergraduate students and if you're
interested in this sort of thing just
give a call or an email to Paul Parra
vano in our office of government and
Community Relations and if you forget
that name send me an email
and finally largely organized through
our political science department we have
a modest scale but really excellent
summer internship program in Washington
and getting MIT students out across both
the government and nonprofit
organizations in Washington is very very
helpful in this regard yes as professors
and mentors to young students and
budding scientists if a talented young
graduate student stepped into your
office and said should I go and get a
post in a productive research university
or should I go and get a job in a
national lab where research has done for
a very directed purpose of national
security what would you tell to her him
what would be your advice i I think both
offer very interesting career
possibilities and I think one has to
find out what motivates the student what
is what if the student really wants to
do this what the student want to teach
does this do want to work primarily in
the laboratory does a student want to
work on a more fundamental research or
more applied research these are all
these are all questions the student
should answer and given the set of
answers one would say that one
opportunity allows you to do more of one
than the other and that's how I would
suggest the student make a decision but
I would not want to tell the student
what he or she should do the student
should decide for him or herself and the
basis of such questions I think the the
answer Jerry is the exact one that I
would give when students come to me for
advice I basically try to lead them to
unveil what they are really interested
in and then allow them to think about
what their they're going to do with
their careers because I I wouldn't want
to and couldn't understand an individual
well enough to say this is the career
path for you or that's the career path
you lead a student to to really being
honest put everything on the table and
then allow them to make the decision
this is a question maybe primarily for
professor Sharpe in particular with
vaccines maybe stepping aside that the
anthrax vaccine was very much in the
press and as a service member I was on
the receiving end of that and you know
there's nothing more intimate than
taking a vaccine into your body for
defense and as a layman it's really
there's some big obstacles understanding
what goes into the making of a vaccine
and the effectiveness especially that
vaccine in particular what are the
responsibilities of the research
community for keeping us educated as
citizens about the efforts of the
government to make these vaccines and is
there a danger that in drawing the
firewalls between yourself and
confidential research that you step out
to the point that you're not protecting
your fellow citizens from government
specific research led by defense doctors
and defense researchers that maybe
aren't as qualified as the best and
brightest outside that I think when you
isolate a community in any way from open
disclosure and criticism from another
community you run the risk of having not
the most critical discussion of the use
of any agent so you know I don't know
the specifics about an anthrax vaccine I
don't know how it was tested what the
nature of the tests were and whether
they were ever published or not but
every time you draw a line saying I
can't disclose this you run the risk
that those individuals inside the line
are not being criticized and scrutinized
to the extent that those on the other
side would if they had access that's all
I can say it seems that the the general
opinion from the panel is that that of a
scientific community saying that
government restrictions of any sort will
impede rather than improve
national security and well I don't
necessarily disagree with that thesis is
is there in your opinion any government
restrictions that would be appropriate
and I mostly ask that question in that
it seems that if that this kind of
dialogue leads to the sounds to someone
who outside of the scientific community
is and all of the scientists locking
arms and saying leave us alone we're
going to govern ourselves we know what's
best and we can do it is there anything
that would be appropriate oh yeah for
the government to say in this there are
many things which are appropriate we
were only talking about certain kinds of
basic research fundamental research I
mean after all in the nuclear arms
development that was all secret and
should be secret well I would never want
to bring such work into a into a campus
area so I I there are always strategic
secrets that have to be protected and I
don't think anybody in the scientific
community would ever say otherwise the
only problem is over over classifying
and extending it to areas work which are
not vital to national security in in
that sense and therefore causing harm to
science and education but I do not want
this you to go away with the idea that
the scientific community is against the
classification of strategic secrets that
certainly is not the case absolutely if
I could just add a little bit to that if
you've listened closely to some of the
themes that have run through this what
we want are very bright distinct clear
lines we think that line is should be
classified or unclassified what we don't
like are these sort of fuzzy terms that
can be can be implemented after the fact
that's why several of us mentioned the
sensitive but unclassified category of
information yes we may allow to ask the
question also I saw it I could sit down
be quiet okay
now this is a very serious one I quit my
job from industry
to help the people the academia people
to meet powder people I create a
symposium called Lila spalling two Nobel
Prize Lila spalling bout has symposium
and I'm have panel discussion academia
with this industry for new drug
discovery I have a hundred speaker for
an industry and can I can hardly find
any speaker from academia so in my panel
I have no academic speaker so question
is that you are sitting here because you
give him back I asked myself they
apparently asked him for money I condemn
a speaker they want me to get the money
but I don't have money to get to them so
how can I get a condemned a speaker to
join my panel discussion for students
and by the way the symposium is fear
charge we have Chinese stem sang-ho
day-long MIT faculty Club okay now
question how could I calm winds these
so-called
professor come to my panel discussion
for one hour I feed them with them some
how can i how can I ask them and they
are more busy than any industry people
well I I don't have an answer to that
but I'm sure you'll find an answer given
your enthusiasm I got sued about emails
don't work if you really want to get
somebody to speak you should speak to
them personally and explain what the
conference is all about and why it's
important you each of us gets so many
emails each day we cannot keep up with
it and I suspect that your email is not
being looked at seriously so if you
really want to get people talk to them
but they don't eyes on my phone call
well please join me in thanking
professors Friedman and sharp but before
we do so I am told that while it may not
be dim sum there are refreshments
available
a lot thank you
[Applause]